mobilisation dans toute la france contre
la réforme de la sécurité sociale et de
la retraite des fonctionnaires sur fond
de différend entre le syndicat les
irlandais ont voté aujourd'hui pour ou
contre la légalisation du divorce dans
leur pays la disparition à 63 ans d'un
des plus grands réalisateurs français
louis malle parmi ses succès lacombe
lucien les amants au revoir les enfants
madame monsieur bonsoir mobilisation
générale aujourd'hui dans toute la
france à l'appel de la cgt de tous les
syndicats de fonctionnaires contre la
réforme de la sécurité sociale et des
retraites de la fonction publique
des manifestations ont eu lieu dans
toutes les grandes villes et à paris
avec des chiffres très éloignés 22000
personnes ont défilé selon la police
entre 50000 et 150 mille selon les
organisateurs jean paul chapelle
frédéric bazille les fonctionnaires ne
veulent pas qu'on touche à leur retraite
et ils sont venus le dire aujourd'hui
sur un air de rock n roll avec un seul
refrain non aux plans d'alain juppé il
ya un mois le gouvernement a décidé de
geler gelé les salaires de
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui s'attaquent à
nous en retraite le mois prochain peut
être qu'à mettre en cause l'abattement
des salariés pour les impôts je crois
qu'il est temps que les gens disent non
et manifeste la retraite quand cet
endroit pour kim eng
après vingt cantons fonctionnaires
encore et 35 ans et demi mais je pense
que je suis pour les gens du privée
pensent bas pour poser ses 37 ans et
demi de ces conventions
beaucoup d'entre eux ont pris leurs
vélos faute de pouvoir utiliser les
transports en commun il tenait à
rejoindre le cortège pour protester
aussi contre la réforme de la sécurité
sociale justice qui consiste à demander
pour l'argent là où on est sûr d'en
trouver le plus parce qu'il a le plus
grand nombre et de la pollution pour
l'évacuer dans la manif les
fonctionnaires sont rejoints par des
salariés du privé mais aussi des
étudiants qui profite de l'occasion pour
faire entendre leur voix
ici les revendications parfois un air de
déjà vu
les fonctionnaires nostalgique garde
quand même beaucoup d'humour
justement je demande des sous parce que
j'ai plus de quoi se faire de nouvelles
pancartes à une poignée moyens pour
avoir des avis plutôt responsabilisation
open comprenez bien sûr les
fonctionnaires ne croit pas au père noël
il compte juste sur leur propre
mobilisation pour défendre leurs
intérêts cette mobilisation dans la
fonction publique a relativement bien
fonctionné à la base
le seul chiffre en notre possession est
celui pour l'instant du ministère de la
fonction publique qui annonce 37 % de
grévistes contre 57 pour cent lors de la
dernier journée de grève
c'était le 10 octobre dernier
mobilisation à la base mais une certaine
confusion à la tête des syndicats avec
notamment un mauvais moment à passer
pour madame nicole notât secrétaire
général de la cfdt qui a quitté
rapidement le cortège contesté par
quelques-uns de ses propres militants
agnès molinier franck brisset elle était
venue soutenir les fonctionnaires cfdt
mais certains militants notamment des
enseignants ne voulait absolument pas
d'elle
le départ brutalement précipité de
nicole notât n'est qu'un nouvel épisode
d'une guerre désormais ouverte à la cfdt
déjà contesté lors de son élection à la
tête du syndicat en mars dernier elle
est aujourd'hui violemment critiqué pour
avoir approuvé le plan de réforme de la
sécurité sociale
la réforme les français et lui même
revenir son terme et nous allons être
vers le monde travaille ans pour que
brooke une déviation ne soit maintenant
pris dans l'application des c'était nous
ne pensons pas ces décisions vont encore
en pensant qu'elles sont contraires aux
intérêts des travailleurs n'ont pas
apprécié la provocation que
constituerait la présence de nicole
notât
c'est pour ça que nous lui avons demandé
fermement en la raccompagne ans jusqu'à
sa voiture
nous lui avons demandé de partir si
force ouvrière était représentée par une
adhérente célèbre arnett leydier son
leader marc blondel n'était pas là car
son syndicat beau défilé mardi avec les
médecins une décision qui n'a pas
empêché cheminots et postiers force
ouvrière de manifester aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui si on veut comme juppé y dit
je ne survivrais pas au parlement sur
ira pas à 2 millions dans la rue ben
c'est pas aux dispersants chacun de son
côté qu'on arrivera un appel à l'union
que semble approuver beaucoup de
salariés qui se sont retrouvés nombreux
aujourd'hui derrière nous fonctionnaires
je ne conteste pas qu'il y a des
différences d'approché au niveau des
états-majors syndicaux
mais ce que je constate c'est que la
volonté unitaire et la volonté de se
rassembler et beaucoup plus forte à la
base que dans les majeures ça croyez moi
c'est porteur d'avenir
un avenir très proche pour la cgt qui
pourrait bien manifester à nouveau dès
mardi avec force ouvrière
dans cette mobilisation il ya eu des
plus et des moins l'edf on a frôlé par
exemple la panne générale à la mi
journée les transports en commun ont été
particulièrement touchées la ratp dans
la région parisienne et la sncf au plan
national on était là proche de la
paralysie totale
voyons maintenant au niveau des usages
et quelles ont été les conséquences de
cette journée de grève laurent bailly
georges ans aucun métro ne circulait cet
après-midi ni ce soir à paris
même chose pour le rer sauf sur la ligne
a et déjà ce matin le trafic était très
perturbé dans les grandes gares
parisiennes le trafic était également
nul pour la banlieue ont fait 17 ans que
je crois c'est la première fois que j'ai
pas du tout pour la province la
situation n'est guère plus brillante
définition d'un train hypothétique en
majorité les usagers n'ont pas pris de
risque les gars étaient quasi-désertes
parmi les rares voyageur virtuel présent
les réactions étaient plutôt variés ça
m'agace vraiment puisqu'on vient de
passer la nuit à la gare
j'aurais pu être chez moi ce matin et
pouvant
ils vont reprendre le travail dimanche
ou lundi et pouvant ainsi mois il
reprend la grève ils en recevront encore
au même point
je sais qu'on va droit de montrer appelé
contentement donc
forcément d'accord avec en surface dans
la rue tous les moyens étaient bons pour
se déplacer par les chauffeurs de taxi
ont été d'autant plus sollicité que les
conducteurs de bus que se faisait rare
les parisiens blasé ont dû prendre leur
mal en patience ce matin à beaucoup de
familles françaises ont dû vivre les
mêmes problèmes ou à peu près écoles
fermées
l'un des deux parents obligés de rester
à la maison l'autre partant à la
recherche d'un transport en commun
vraiment hypothétique florence duprat
pierre lepetit
il est 7h30 à champigny sur marne la
famille magnol se réveille doucement
et pour une fois tout le monde se
retrouve autour d'un café tartine lui
cette amère jonathan et aurélie les
enfants lionel le père aujourd'hui
lucette a du temps pour s'occuper de sa
petite famille grève oblige elle ne peut
pas d'aller travailler
le petit n'a pas de maîtresse et donc à
personne que la culture quoi donc
alors ya les mamies effectivement mais
ma belle-mère et 100 mile house
travailler ou non ça veut dire qu'il
faut la voiture ou alors il faut prendre
les transports
et c'est fabien pratique était content
de pas l'école non pourquoi
parce que la récole aurélie qui malgré
la grève a cours au collège n'est pas du
tout cet avis là qu'ils se comparent
cours et non la course essayer autant
8h15
le père de famille s'apprête à les
affronter la galère des transports en
commun dessinateur industriel il a
l'habitude de prendre le bus pour se
rendre sur son lieu de travail à dix
kilomètres de là
de longues minutes d'attentes et
toujours aucun bus à l'horizon lionel
déclare forfait
je veux y aller à pied
heureusement lyonnais laisse porte et
c'est d'un pas alerte qu'il entame une
heure de marche à pied
à mi parcours il tente le stop mais les
automobilistes n'ont pas de pitié pour
les marcheurs pendant ce temps la
lucette qui gardent thomas le copain de
jonathan profite de sa journée avec les
enfants déjà un avant-goût du week-end
le temps d'une partie de cartes
lionel est enfin arrivé au bureau mais
en retard à la galère de la marche
s'ajoute aussi un petit regret et j'ai
eu la possibilité déchets chez serait
allé avec plaisir surtout qui fait
mauvais mais ce soir coup de chance
c'est un collègue qu'il la raccompagnait
et comme chaque fois dans ce type de
circonstances il ya parmi les français
des débrouillards qui appliquent le
fameux système d pour essayer à tout
prix de rejoindre leur lieu de travail
pascal golomer question autant ni métro
ni bus et une chambre air qui rend l'âme
au plus mauvais moment
vraiment il y a des jours où tout va mal
ce n'est pas encore dimanche mais ils
ont déjà envahi les rues de paris
piétons et cyclistes en tout genre avec
ou sans accessoires
il y en a pour tous les goûts et pour
tous les styles
catégorie 2 roues et sans moteur version
élégance version tout terrain
certains ont l'entraînement d'autres un
tout petit peu moins la première fois de
l'année bas depuis septembre et vous
aimez ça oui j'aime beaucoup peut-être
que je le reprendrais maintenant après
dans la catégorie piétons ils y allaient
presser les très pressé je lui envoie un
avion
il y a aussi quelques artistes inspirés
mais pourquoi pas se mettre en forme
on respire les gaz carboniques ce
formidable à propos d' artistes certains
touristes auront apprécié le louvre
fermé de l'extérieur tous les transports
sont bolt est donc ce n'est pas ça va
pouvoir faire grand chose
quant aux automobilistes
beaucoup sont encore bloqués sur les
routes rêvant peut-être d'une vie sans
embouteillages est sans grève mais ce
n'est encore qu'un rêve mobilisation
dans toute la france je vous lisez en
commençant est relativement même plus
importante dans les grandes villes de
province que dans la capitale cinquante
mille personnes par exemple dans les
rues à marseille ce matin dix mille à
lille
25000 à toulouse où des salariés du
secteur privé ont également défilé en
compagnie des étudiants christophe la
rocca gilbert rozon
vingt-cinq mille manifestants dans les
rues de toulouse un cortège de plus de
deux kilomètres derrière un seul mot
d'ordre défendre la protection sociale
dans la foule beaucoup d'enseignants de
postiers ou de cheminots les salariés du
privé sont en majorité affiliés à la cgt
ils refusent en bloc le plan juppé est
inacceptable jugé comme tel et rejeté
par la rue par la grève et la puissance
de la manifestation dans le cortège
une délégation de force ouvrière mais
surtout de la cfdt la haute garonne est
un des trente-quatre départements où les
cédétistes contrairement à la consigne
nationale appelé le secteur privé à la
grève pour les responsables
départementaux les points négatifs
contenues dans le plan juppé l'emportent
nettement sur les aspects positifs en
tant que représentante de l'union
départementale je suis parfaitement à
l'aise dans ce cortège est la preuve est
que c'est que le porter c'est bb
aujourd'hui nombreux dans la rue une rue
où l'on parlait beaucoup de
l'allongement à 40 ans des cotisations
retraite pour les fonctionnaires
une mesure présentée par le gouvernement
comme le rattrapage une injustice face
au secteur privé mais il ya injustice
entre public et privé
c'est évident mais il faut plutôt la
justice dans les 37 ans que la justice
dans les 40 m en fin de cortège pour ne
pas ravir la vedette aux salariés 3000
étudiants fermait la marche
leur grand manifestation à eux aura lieu
sur ces mêmes boulevard jeudi prochain
après toulouse d'autres villes d'autres
défilés en commençant par bordeaux la
ville du premier ministre sophie jour
sébastien guibert à bordeaux la
manifestation était un peu particulière
c'est au nombre de 25 milles qu'ils ont
protesté
autant contre la réforme de la sécu que
contre le premier ministre qui est aussi
maire de la ville
cgt fo cfdt ont formé l'essentiel du
cortège composé de toutes les
professions postiers cheminots et
dockers en tête
pour la sauver les bretons de la voix et
de bonnes semaines ils étaient vingt
mille dans les rues de rennes plus
nombreux encore que le 10 octobre pour
la défense des salaires même des
salariés du privé sont venus en renfort
la grève pour la sécu a été suivie à 70%
la poste à 50% chez les enseignants
perturbations aussi dans les transports
aucun bus n'a montré son nez dans le
nord pas de calais ce sont les usagers
qui se sont cassé le nez portait
guichets fermés gare déserte trafic
quasiment nul
la grève de la fonction publique a
particulièrement été suivies et cet
après midi plus de dix mille
manifestants fonctionnaires et étudiants
ont défilé dans les rues bling à lyon
étudiants et lycéens ont rejoint le
cortège
véritable serpent de quatre kilomètres
de long les syndicats ont défilé en
ordre dispersé la cgt rassemblant le
plus gros des troupes
dans l'ensemble la journée de grève
s'est plutôt bien déroulé beaucoups de
lyonnais sont réfléchies les
fonctionnaires de la région marseillaise
ce ne sont pas vraiment rester chez eux
ils ont défilé à plus de 40 milles en
compagnie de nombreux étudiants dans les
rues de la cité phocéenne pour défendre
la protection sociale parmi les
conséquences de ces journées de grève
pour les non grévistes essentiellement
dans le secteur privé
les journées de travail des comptes est
prise sur les journées de vacances
conscient du problème une société
parisienne d'assurance a mis au point un
système moins pénalisant pour ses
employés maryse burgot d'idées dans une
chaise vide
une autre chaise vide un bureau presque
désert on se serait cru en week end
aujourd'hui on siège du groupe
ferrer spécialiste des assurances c'est
que le patron lui-même avait encouragé
tous les salariés presque à rester chez
eux
il est inutile que de demander à des
personnes de se lever très tôt le matin
de passer trois heures à essayer de
trouver des moyens de transport voici
donc les quelques courageuses qui sont
venus quand même une dizaine de salariés
sur deux sens sur la possible
il venir d'un coup j'ai accepté d'ouvrir
la permanence j'ai la possibilité de
venir ok j'en avais pour votre retour et
de marche
il fallait rattraper les heures car pour
celles qui sont restées chez elles la
journée n'était évidemment pas de cadeau
il faudra choisir entre une journée de
vacances en moins ou huit heures de
travail à rattraper dans les semaines
qui viennent
comme cette jeune femme 90 % des
salariés sont quand même décidé de
rester chez eux pour éviter la galère
d'une journée de grève étant donné qu'il
n'y avait pas beaucoup de trains qu'elle
n'a pas donc effectivement je préférais
rester chez moi et surtout étant donné
que mon fils n'avait pas classe donc
j'ai pu le garder ça m'a permis de le
garder tranquillement une idée de
gestion du personnel qui finalement
arrange aussi beaucoup l'employeur
puisque de toute façon aujourd'hui les
salariés ont répété très ponctuel avant
d'aller plus loin un coup d'oeil sur la
circulation automobile aujourd'hui
autour des grandes métropoles et
principalement paris sur ces images avec
des bouchons qui ont atteint 25 km à
l'ouest de la capitale ce matin et ce
soir un retour plus souvent aléatoire
qui se conjugue avec certains départs en
week end dernier secteur en difficulté
aujourd'hui les transports aériens qui
n'étaient pas en live à proprement
parler mais qui ont subi les arrêts de
travail des contrôleurs du ciel luc
baziz un dernier relais avant l'heure ce
n'est pas l'heure
donc il faut patienter à chacun sa façon
quelles que soient les destinations et
les compagnies les panneaux d'affichage
laisse apprécier l'ampleur de ce
mouvement de grève
80 % des contrôleurs aériens ont
emprunté la casquette de grévistes
résultat un trafic minimum avec une
majorité d'avions cloués au sol
en fait seuls 16% des vols étaient
maintenus donc de longues heures
d'attentes certains étaient un peu
rêveur d'autres plus philosophe ce matin
à 1 n'ayant pas l'avion on a vu partir
hier soir
donc ça nous fait deux jours de perdus
pratiquement laurent matter on prend
notre mal en patience
viens boire un coup en lui et pis il ya
plus à faire
je devais partir à 16h40 et donc
maintenant je suis obligé de prendre le
vol
voilà 20h40 donc ça m'a depuis 10 heures
ce matin
ce soir l'aérogare d'orly et plein de
passagers tout aussi inquiet en fait les
contrôleurs aériens ont paralysé le ciel
pour exprimer leur désaccord sur la
réorganisation du système des retraites
le syndicat des contrôleurs aériens
annonce l'arrêt de ce mouvement de grève
demain matin à 6h30 on peut donc
s'attendre à une reprise progressive du
trafic aérien pour retrouver une
situation normale en milieu de matinée
en terme de cette journée de grève qui
avait été décidée pour 24 heures il faut
faire le point elle va notamment se
poursuivre dans certains secteurs
jusqu'à demain au moins yannick
letranchant yannick est ce que vous
m'entendez oui parfaitement donc vous
utilisez fin de la grève pour
aujourd'hui mais dans d'autres dans
certains secteurs elle se poursuit
demain notamment
oui alors ici on le voit on est à saint
lazare on est en plein désert ou presque
et ça risque d'être à nouveau le désert
dès demain avec une reconduction de la
grève des cheminots avec à prévoir moins
d'1 train sur quatre sur le trafic
grandes lignes et 0 train comme
aujourd'hui est sûre la banlieue alors
d'une manière plus générale yannick la
suite des événements jusqu'à la semaine
prochaine
oui et d'écouté on l'a vu là dans les
différents reportages la mobilisation
était forte a été très forte à paris
ainsi qu'en province une mobilisation
avec comme mot d'ordre le rejet du plan
de réforme de la sécurité sociale
le rejet du plan de réforme des
retraites des fonctionnaires une
mobilisation très forte sur fond de
désignons de désunion des syndicats
désunion niveau des principaux leaders
bien sûr et non pas de la base à leur
grève à l'appel de quelques-uns pour
aujourd'hui grèves très suivies nouvelle
grève à prévoir mardi prochain le 28 à
l'appel de force ouvrière dans un
premier temps rejoint désormais par la
cgt à l'heure face à la grogne que peut
faire le gouvernement juppé alors on
sait qu'il entend maintenir le cap mais
il est aussi très vite discuter
dialoguer avec les uns et les autres
alors on connaîtra en début de semaine
prochaine lundi ou mardi prochain selon
nos informations la composition de la
commission chargée de plancher sur la
réforme du régime de retraite des
fonctionnaires avec des résultats prévue
pour le mois de mars prochain c'est à
dire dans quatre mois alors le
gouvernement va devoir jouer très serré
si je puise
hier face à la montée de ces inquiétudes
de ses peurs chez les fonctionnaires et
chez les étudiants on l'a vu la semaine
dernière on l'a vu encore aujourd'hui on
le fera on le verra sans doute encore
mardi prochain alors c'était un petit
peu des journées tests les tests sont
réussis pour les manifestants c'est un
test plus inquiétant pour le
gouvernement
merci yannick est la cgt annonce ce soir
un chiffre d'un million de personnes qui
ont d'une manière ou d'une autre
manifesté en france aujourd'hui comme
vient de le dire
yannick letranchant quoi qu'il en soit
le gouvernement entend bien maintenir le
cap de la réforme le ministre des
affaires sociales monsieur barreaux le
disais dans notre journal de 13 heures
il n'y a pas d'autre solution
monsieur baron les français un petit peu
obsédé on les comprend par les
inquiétudes immédiates ne regarde pas un
peu l'avenir l'avenir c'est un horizon
dégagé
si nous essayons d'éliminer les déficits
c'est beaucoup la france marche un bon
parent crée des emplois et je suis
convaincu je suis pas le seul parce qu'à
l'extérieur
il ya déjà des signes qui montrent que
la france inspire confiance et des
investissements par exemple comme celui
d' ib m
il ya des taux d'intérêt qui baissent il
ya bien à l'extérieur de la confiance
mais à l'intérieur c'est un peu nos
peurs nous inquiétudes qui s'expriment
aujourd'hui deux chiffres encore dans le
contexte d'aujourd'hui qui ont leur
importance
la consommation des ménages d'abord qui
a baissé de 4 4% en octobre dernier
quant au commerce extérieur il a
enregistré au mois de septembre un
excédent de près de 8 milliards de
francs le commerce extérieur français
est excédentaire depuis le début de
cette année l'actualité internationale
maintenant avec un référendum
aujourd'hui en irlande pour ou contre la
légalisation du divorce pays catholique
à plus de 90% et le dernier en europe a
refusé la séparation officielle des
couples des résultats qui s'annoncent
très serrés ne seront connus que demain
eric lemasson guillon faudra à quelques
mètres seulement de l'église dennis
kelly 10 700 habitants le bureau de vote
voilà bien tout le symbole du référendum
irlandais quelle influence la tradition
catholique at elle encore non seulement
sur les âmes mais aussi sur les
institutions de la république irlandaise
il y a neuf ans ce village comme le pays
tout entier avait rejeté la légalisation
du divorce
mais aujourd'hui même si 60% des
habitants danis kerry seront encore
chaque dimanche à la messe
même le prêtre est plus modéré qu
autrefois weeks
ces dernières semaines nous avons
expliqué aux gens la doctrine catholique
sur ce sujet c'est ce qu'ils attendent
de moi bien sûr mais nous leur avons dit
aussi d'écouter les débats et les
discussions à la télé et de réagir selon
leur conscience pour forger leur propre
opinion
difficile de savoir si derrière ces
portes et dans le secret des alcôves les
couples irlandais sont plus fidèles
qu'ailleurs mais peu importe pour les
partisans du non au référendum
l'essentiel est de préserver le
fondement même de la société la famille
ainsi chez les boucler un couple
d'architectes de la banlieue de dublin
les buckley cet enfant 29 ans de mariage
et une certaine idée de la famille
traditionnelle scellé par les liens
sacrés du mariage
oui mais au jour de notre mariage nous
avons pris un engagement pour la vie
pour le meilleur et pour le pire
alors bien sûr comme tous les couples
nous rencontrons parfois des difficultés
mais c'est justement dans les moments
difficiles qu'un couple a besoin que la
société lui offre son soutien et sa
stabilité
mais l'irlande a changé dans les rues de
dublin les couples se forment mais
parfois aussi se sépare en dix ans le
nombre de séparations a doublé nous nous
battons l'autorisation de divorcer dans
ce pays car quand les couples se
séparent
il faut qu'ils aient le choix qu'ils
soient libres de se remarier s'ils le
souhaitent pendant des semaines
la campagne électorale a suscité bien
des passions combat de la modernité
libérale
les partisans du oui contre la stabilité
et la tradition les partisans du non
c'est en tout cas une certaine idée de
l'irlande qui est en jeu aujourd'hui
dans le secret des urnes
en bref confusion en algérie le front
islamique du salut fait savoir que la
lettre de l'un de ses principaux
responsables
rabah kebir exilé en europe
reconnaissant l'élection du président
zeroual les tunis
tif personnelle qui n'engage en rien le
mouvement frayeur aujourd'hui à moscou
des résistants tchétchène annonçait
avoir déposé un colis radioactifs au
coeur de la vie finalement ce colis
n'était pas dangereux il n'en reste pas
moins que rétrospectivement l'inquiétude
reste la même
dominique derda michel aulas c'est une
journaliste russe spécialiste de la
tchétchénie sur la chaîne privée ntv qui
sous quelques centimètres de feuilles
mortes et de neige allait couvert le
paquet radio
la scène se déroule et hier après midi
dans un parc à l'est de moscou
les radiations émises sont selon ntv
plusieurs dizaines de fois supérieur aux
normes habituellement admises en russie
si les nations que la journaliste est
arrivé jusqu'ici ce n'est pas par hasard
c'est chamil bassaïev lui même dit elle
qui lui indiquer l'endroit où se
trouvait l'engin
depuis la sanglante prise d'otages de
bougneau 9 15 juin dernier chamil
bassaïev et le plus célèbre des
combattants tchétchènes
il est en théorie recherché par toutes
les polices toutes les forces armées
tous les services secrets russes
pourtant dans son village de montagne il
multiplie les conférences de presse les
le 8 novembre dernier encore il
avertissait le table 1 qu'il avait les
moyens de porter la guerre jusque à
moscou de nombreuses personnes disaient
ils alors maintenant que nous le font
que nous sommes incapables de faire quoi
que ce soit moi je voilà pourquoi on va
leur revenir
est ce qu'un petit cadeau pour leur
démontrer notre bonne volonté et chamil
bassaïev de tendre vers la caméra les
photos de conteneurs radioactifs qui
selon lui serait déjà dissimulé à moscou
ce soir le porte parole de l'ex kgb
affirme bien évidemment qu'il s'agit là
d'une provocation que l'engin découvert
et sans danger il contiendrait du césium
137 et serviraient à vérifier la qualité
des soudures sur les oléoducs de tels
instruments sont très répandus dans les
régions pétrolières en tchétchénie
notamment quoi qu'il en soit chamil
bassaïev a sans doute atteint l'objectif
qu'il s'était fixé montré qu'il pouvait
à tout moment des pauses et où bon lui
semble un pétard de carnaval ou bien une
véritable boom violente explosion au
coeur de l'etna ce matin le volcan a
projeté des pierres et une pluie de
cendres là
l'état s'est violemment réveillé il faut
le dire depuis le début du mois
d'octobre
maintenant on le sait demeure
constamment en éveil en revanche il n'y
a plus d'un siècle que la frontière
entre israël et l'egypte n'avait pas
connu de tremblement de terre il y en a
eu deux cette semaine dont un ce soir
charles enderlin un rabbin cabaliste
avait prévu pour dimanche dernier un
tremblement de terre qui détruirait la
moitié du pays visiblement il s'est
trompé sur la date et l'intensité du
séisme la terre promise à trembler une
première fois mercredi avec une
intensité de 7,1 sur l'échelle de
richter
les dégâts les plus importants ont été
relevés à eilat un visiteur est décédé
d'une crise cardiaque
plus au sud en egypte sur la côte du
sinaï
l'effondrement d'un hôtel a fait quatre
morts jeudi soir nouveau séisme moins
important ressentiez également à eilat
que les touristes commencent à déserter
l'épicentre se trouve à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres au sud dans le
golfe d'aqaba à court terme les
spécialistes se veulent rassurants les
répliques du séisme de mercredi devrait
être de plus en plus faible à moyen
terme
ils sont plus inquiets la grande faille
de la mer morte se réveille après avoir
dormi pendant un siècle la partie
arabique de la plaque continentale bouge
vers le nord par rapport au sinaï
cette région a connu des tremblements de
terre meurtrier depuis l'antiquité
c'est ici que la bible situe l'histoire
de sodome et gomorrhe détruit par le feu
et le soufre retour en france jusqu'à
l'arrivée du front national à la tête de
la mairie de toulon en juin dernier la
fête annuelle du livre était un
événement comme un autre n'est plus le
cas aujourd'hui la municipalité en effet
décidé d'imposer la présence de
plusieurs écrivains d'extrême droite ce
qui a provoqué une très vive réaction
michaël darmon christophe vidal un
journal satirique a sauté sur poulon la
veille de la fête du livre atterrissage
tout d'abord sur une scène toulonnaise
aux côtés de renault histoire de donner
le la
c'est un concert et d'artistes et de
militants le citoyen de militants et
sert de résistance que manifester ma
résistance au fascisme ma solidarité
avec les anti fascistes de toulon gardes
du corps et caméras de leur côté cabu
wolinski et des autres ne sont pas
passés inaperçus dans la ville en route
pour la fête du livre cette année
transformée en ring politico médiatique
à l'extrême gauche tout d'abord le stand
charlie hebdo très visité le temps je
regarde les regards de tous c'est
quelquefois parts intéressant quelqu'un
de tolérant
à l'extrême droite le stand des auteurs
présents proches du front national
plutôt désert à cause des retards
d'avion mais les élus les sympathisants
sont là où l'on reparle de tolérance
avec la presse
mais sur un autre ton nous avons gagné
sans vous mêmes qu'au fond on sait pas
maintenant que je vais regarder ce sont
les seules vraies plantes et les gens du
front national mon vote ne leur prend
mon poing levé relative et entre
partisans et combattants du front
national il n'y avait aujourd'hui un
organisateur plutôt désabusé que je
regrette c'est que de part et d'autre on
a tendance à prendre un petit peu en
otage la manifestation pour en faire un
champ de foire politique ce qui est pas
du tout la nature de cette fête du livre
un petit tour et puis s'en vont après
charlie hebdo ce sera au tour de mains
de martine aubry devenir de néri si ces
recettes pour lutter contre le front
national dans une ville transformée en
laboratoire politique
ça se passe toujours dans la même région
de toulon le conseiller général du var
joseph cerciat incarcéré depuis le 31
août pour notamment trafic d'influencé a
été remis ce soir en liberté provisoire
bon l'histoire des asticots dans le
matelas
c'était la combine de marchands
indélicats de literie qui s'intéressent
sur s'intéresser surtout pardon aux
personnes âgées avec qui il faisait de
très bonnes affaires
sandra smit didier goux
madame reagan aime bien que son
intérieur soit propre
le 28 octobre dernier elle reçoit la
visite de deux hommes que son mari
croiser dans le quartier avec son chien
une visite de courtoisie pour ceux qui
se prétendent marchand de meubles
une visite qui va se transformer en
cauchemar dans la chambre à coucher
il a soulevé ici et là ou vers le
matelas d'abord et le sommier ici
ensuite
et alors ils avaient des asticots dans
la main avec des asticots et dans le
matelas est d'attirer la mousse est
tombé en fait les simples petites bêtes
venait tout droit de la poche de
l'escroc comme par hasard un nid tout
neuf est disponible dans une camionnette
stationnée en bas de l'immeuble
dégoûté par les asticots madame rigal
accepte un prix un peu cher
treize mille francs payés avec lettres
chèques comme elle ne reçoit pas la
facture promise la victime va soupçonner
un peu tard l'escroquerie elle va faire
opposition à la banque mais 9000 francs
auront été encaissés pour cette nouvelle
couche se lit vous dormez bien dessus en
maintenant oui bon alors même si mon
mari me rappelle quelqu'un je ne
laissent leur entrée c'est terminé ça
deux jours après celle a eu la visite de
personnes qui sont venues pour une
alarme
eh bien ils ont été servis en beauté à
nice le gang des asticots court toujours
quatre personnes ont porté plainte mais
les colporteurs en tout genre risquent
de voir plusieurs portes se fermaient
disparition d'un des plus grands
réalisateurs français de cinéma louis
malle qui vient de mourir à los angeles
à l'âge de 63 ans victime d'une maladie
des ganglions lymphatiques louis malle
fut l'un des seuls réalisateurs français
a mené une double carrière d'ailleurs en
france et aux etats-unis parmi ses
succès les plus importants les amants
avec jeanne moreau zazie dans le métro
lacombe lucien viva maria et puis encore
un film tout particulier au revoir les
enfants qui racontait sa propre jeunesse
pendant la guerre parce qu'à des champs
voir les enfants bientôt parmi les
petits élèves qui assiste dans une cour
de collège
un matin de l'hiver 44 à l'arrestation
par les allemands de 3 enfants juifs et
du prêtre qu'il est caché
il y à l'élève louis malle 11 ans devenu
cinéaste
il attendra 40 ans pour en faire un film
plus de 40 ans ont passé et jusqu'à ma
mort je me rappellerai chaque seconde de
ce matin de janvier
j'ai été sept enfants qui a été
complètement indigné de découvrir
brutalement l'existence de la tolérance
du racisme de la violence de l'injustice
si ce film lui valu sept césars sous les
yeux de sa femme candice bergen
l'assentiment d'un large public
il ne doit pas faire oublier l'offre
complexe et d'un cinéaste qui émettent
aussi flirté avec une scandale quand il
filme et les étreintes des amants et 30
pour lesquelles une jeune femme quitter
mari et enfants ou quand il donnait de
la couleur aux mots de raymond queneau
et pas de la politique c'est pour la
croûte qu'en trente deux ans plus tard
il fut ce qui jette avec d'autres
étreinte dans fatal la froideur et
l'hypocrisie lui familles anglaises ou
quand en 1968 membre du jury du festival
de cannes
il faisait souffler avec ses amis godard
et truffaut le vent de la contestation
sur la croisette
un festival qu'il finira par présidé en
1993 mais cet explorateur des
comportements qui épinglait avec
élégance tabous et préjugés n'avait pas
choisi de son propre aveu le septième
art pour faire des films de pur
divertissement crois que je suis devenu
je le dis je crois je donne une idée
assez parce que j'ai dit à ma mère un
peu par provocation que vous les
metteurs en scène j'avais 13 ans était
tellement surpris la pauvre femme
qu'elle m'a filé une claque
je crois que cette claque a beaucoup
pour tribut à la location
1 si je n'entendais pas ta voix je
serais perdu un fils de famille jean
renoir qui l'admiré temps louis malle
aura donc tenu bon réalisant 25 films du
monde du silence à vagnas 42e rue en
passant par ascenseur pour l'échafaud où
le voleur couvert de prix il disait il
ne faudrait pas faire des films pour
plaire à tout le monde parce que
s'adressèrent à tout le monde amène à se
censurer a devancé les désirs supposés
du public a donné un produit mièvre tout
le contraire de l'oeuvre qu'il nous
laisse
merci
les france 2 rediffusera ce soir à 22h35
un bouillon de culture du bout des
doigts un extrait et qui était consacrée
à louis malle 7 et en 1993 une pièce de
théâtre assez insolite se joue
actuellement sous un chapiteau à
nanterre dans la banlieue parisienne son
titre déjà les trois mousquetaires ou le
petit d'artagnan comme son nom l'indiqué
il s'agit des aventures du célèbre
mousquetaire
alors qu'il était tout jeune et qu'il
rêvait de devenir le héros d'alexandre
dumas
un spectacle pour les enfants aux
approches de noël mais aussi pour les
parents avec notamment des scènes
franchement drôle comme cet incroyable
mêlée de rugby autour de la cassette des
ferrets de la reine jarre dalmaz daniel
faire tous pour un un porte aus la
fresque pour enfants débutants gascogne
la ferme familiale terrain de jeu idéal
le futur d'artagnan n'a que 12 ans et
croise déjà le faire avec son épée de
bois
il veut devenir mousquetaire en
chahutant le gamin est expédiée au pays
des songes
il rêve son avenir en transformant tous
ses proches en personnages de la cour
lui-même étant porteur de la cap et de
l'épée au service du roi et surtout de
la reine
en plein dedans c'est de faire un peu de
tout c'est à dire je fais n'a cascades
je chante bon avant tout comédien
échassiers
il ya du tout aller au combat ce crime
quarante comédiens musiciens acrobates
kabange qui fort bien s'escrime à manier
la rapière chance laissée aller venez me
love
il est temps de rendre le coffret ovale
des ferrets de la reine va falloir
tenter un essai entre les lignes des
gardes du cardinal qui ne rêve que de
mêlée ouverte
c'est comme au cinéma mais on devrait
alors quelques avis de marmousets et
damoiselles dégringolé des gradins
j'ai adoré très bien ce qui peut plus ma
grande
alors voilà dans un instant la météo
laurent romejko 20h50 les cinq dernières
minutes
22h35 bouillon de culture dont consacrée
à louis malle qui vient de disparaître
aujourd'hui minuit géopolis claude
sérillon une heure du matin le journal
de la nuit avec florence eu d'eau chez
quant à nous on se retrouve demain à 13h
au revoir bonne soirée sur notre chaîne
à demain